hey y'all it's Yara and I'm here with
the cast of grown --is-- we are gonna
play a BuzzFeed quiz to find out which
character we are mostly right so hit
play damn playing now right now what are
you majoring in kris Jenner's business
basics absolutely that I'm doing
Christian or basic and I'm gonna have
the cam recorder in my hand I did the
studying party because I want to stay
here closely relax
sorry I say I'm gonna do a dull teen
because I need to learn how to I shows
adulting because if I could create a
high school course would be a P common
sense and I feel like I'd be the college
version where are you going for spring
break
I want Greece I want Portugal I'm gonna
do Thailand pick it off campus apartment
I'm gonna pick the Getty Images on I'm
like the blackbaud which word would your
BFF used to describe you this always
feels like the right 500 words about
yourself I was gonna say caring for you
all of the above you have to choose one
I pick creative and I think funny great
for highly fearless between it's between
ambitious creative and caring
I'll say King
I care a lot take a snack for late night
study sessions 100% chips you know
hardens to make avocado toast yeah
that's like sweet night avocado toast
you already have your life together why
would you get kicked out of class
texting taking too many selfies going
live on Instagram challenging the
professors patriarchal views found it to
film a dance challenge watching Netflix
showing up late two weeks straight using
too many gifts in your presentation I
used to get kicked out of class in high
school you did for talking I was too
much the teachers pay you know
challenging the professor probably for
me I would do that too laughs I'm Tom
Joey's I'm Zoey Johnson guys I see that
[Applause]
I'm Lucas okay guys we got a trip I
guess thanks the BuzzFeed for having us
it's great stuff great guy school Oh
make sure you tune in to brownish
Wednesday nights at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
and Pacific 7:00 central if you don't
watch garnish from coming to your house
I'm gonna kick in your ass and cook you
cookies
well tone into the show we love you
[Music]